meets scuba this little gal might not
look like a bloodhound but she helped
out National Geographic in a huge way my
name is Alan Turkic and I build cameras
for National Geographic and my job takes
me all over the world deploying these
camera systems probably one of the most
devastating losses of the camera was
with the system that we call the drift
cannon
we spent about a year developing these
two cameras and we took them to Miami to
deploy them for the first time in the
ocean we went out in the middle of this
crazy storm and we put them into the
water went below the surface
when they came back to the surface they
were caught in one of the fastest ocean
currents on earth and basically they
were just ripped out to sea and taken
further than what was safe for us to
follow that and at that point they they
were lost so how does this little gal
become our hero so it's three years
later and we've just been contacted by
this French guy who is sailing across
the Atlantic and he's found one of our
cameras literally in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean we're talking thousands
and thousands of miles away from where
we originally deployed them with a very
good day more wind and the Maeder them
began to buck
and we saw this ball was lighting with
the Sun so we decide to to change away
and to approach it we saw it was full of
her electrics we thought it was if it
could be in camera but we know we was
not sure and we saw this way it was a
coming from national Geographics
getting the camera back was incredible I
mean it survived for three years
floating on the ocean which I don't know
it says pretty good things about the
design in general but not only that
there was footage on the camera and that
can actually be used for research our
scientists dr. Neil hammer Schlag he's
going to review this footage to get an
understanding of the organisms that live
at those depths in the ocean it's not
every day a dog with sea legs gets the
help National Geographic study the
oceans I can't think of a better ending
to this story not only did we find a
puppy but we found arguably one of the
cutest puppies in the world he'd been
abandoned